We don't from a statistical perspective that if you're intelligent.
So if you have a high Iq,
which just some degrees matter of chance,
by the way,
um,
unless you think you had some choice in picking your parents or if their entire
evolutionary history.
So if you're,
if you have a high Iq and your conscientious,
which is another trait,
then you're more likely to be financials financially successful,
say by the time you in middle age.
And so that looks like a temperamental,
too temperamental traits whose presence enables you to beat randomness over
time.
But you could object to that and say,
well,
that happens to be true for this society at this point in time.
And that's probably true because I think imagine conscientious people store more
value,
they hoard more things well in a different society that would just make you a
target for murder.
Okay.
So those,
those traits work very well in this society at that,
this time.
But you could also argue that that's also a matter of chance because there
wouldn't be unconscientious people if at some point in the past unconscientious
snus hadn't aided their survival.
Yeah.
So what constitutes beating a system depends on the parameters that you put
around the system and you know that you can think the same thing about,
well,
look at how successful he is.
Okay.
You mean financially?
All right,
so then,
well,
how's his health?
How was his marriage?
However,
his relationships with his children,
what price did he pay for his wealth?
You know,
like as you,
as you add dimensions of the valuation,
whether that particular person won or lost might not be so self evident.